now despite the mob and the media's high
praise of president joe biden
it's getting harder and harder for the
biden protection program
to hide joe's erratic outbursts and
downright
nasty comments now just this week during
his big
summit with vladimir putin biden snapped
at a cnn reporter when she asked a very
reasonable question
take a look why are you so confident
he'll change his behavior mr president
of course biden's most recent outburst
is just the latest in a pattern of
lashing out at reporters
when they ask questions that he just
doesn't like take a look at this
how was your role as vice president in
in charge of policy in ukraine
in your son's job how is that not a
conflict of interest
it's not a constant convince there's
been no indication of any conflict of
interest
from ukraine or anywhere else period i'm
not gonna i'm not gonna respond to that
let's focus on the problem focus on this
man
what he's doing that no president has
ever done
no president it's a long way until
november we got
more questions you got more questions
but i tell you that if you have a
problem figuring out whether you're for
me or
trump and you ain't black
when i announced that you all said it's
not possible come on give me a break man
meanwhile podcast host joe rogan has had
just enough of this far left hypocrisy
and called out fake news cnn's brian
seltzer
this week listen to this
they were saying there's people on
youtube right now that get
more views in this show this is because
the market is spoken
right and your show's terrible brian
stelter talking to the press secretary
saying what are we doing wrong
what are we doing wrong like hey mother
you're supposed to be a journalist
joining me now for reaction fox news
contributor joe concha
alongside conservative columnist monica
crowley
all right good evening to both of you
joe i'll start with you
the mob in the media's high praise is
really stunning to me i mean how do
these people look themselves in the
mirror
after they talk about how great joe
biden is when he is literally
falling apart in front of us
well judge i guess they look at the
mirror and then they
turn to their perhaps something next to
their bed
where they they keep maybe a little safe
sort of thing and they count their money
and they say oh okay
it's all okay we we could be as phony as
as we appear to be
uh look a couple things to unpack here
uh caitlyn collins
should be profoundly disappointed with
many of her colleagues who didn't run to
twitter who didn't run on the air
to defend her after that question it
shows you how phony the outrage was
when donald trump pushed back against
reporters when he felt there was an
unfair or
dishonest question that was posed but
here's the reason why there was no joint
presser
between vladimir putin and joe biden
because biden's mo judge is on the rare
occasions he actually does a press
conference
take maybe seven eight nine questions
from hand-picked reporters
chosen by his handlers from there he
reads some of those answers verbatim
off of note cards written for him then
he runs off the stage maybe takes one
question
on the way out if biden was paired with
putin he would not have and he being
putin would not have allowed biden
to leave so quickly he'd probably keep
him on stage for an hour
maybe two hours like a heavyweight
championship where
one fighter knows that he's going to
beat the other one but he wants to
punish him for a while
he would force him to take multiple
questions outside of his comfort zone
while testing
biden's mental endurance and based on
biden's meltdown over one decent
question by
kate and collins that would have been a
catastrophe judge
well and you know monica the amazing
part of this
also is that you've now have joe rogan
who is
loved uh has an incredible podcast
who's calling out cnn brian selter
and you know criticizing him saying he's
basically
a uh you know uh not a great guy not a
great journalist
yes and i give total props to joe rogan
for calling out ryan stelter
and all of his colleagues at at cnn look
rogan
is thriving because he's authentic he's
an independent thinker
and people are starved for that because
they're not getting it from the
propagandists in the media
so his audience has just exploded
because people want
no bs no nonsense they want the truth
they are certainly not getting it from
brian stelter and cnn
and you know what's so revealing about
that exchange
and biden's reaction to caitlyn collins
is it shows how
thin skinned and how what what a short
fuse joe biden has right because that
question
came from a reporter at cnn the most
sycophantic
boot-licking pro-democrat network and
biden still blew a gasket
that points to a bigger issue judge for
decades
democrats leftists progressives they
have been
so coddled and so protected
by the so-called mainstream media that
they're not used to getting
a tough question and by the way that
question from cnn was
thoroughly benign they're not used to
being challenged even in the most
benign kind of way because they never
have so when they're confronted with a
question
like do you think and are you confident
that putin is going to change
he blows up and you see this time and
again he's used to getting questions
like what is your favorite flavor of ice
cream
like he got it monica let me ask you
madness
american people are not getting the
truth monica when you say that it points
to a bigger issue
not just the coddling by the mainstream
media
but the irritability and you know the
sentences that seem to have no
end and go on and on are they
signs of a bigger cognitive issue
well that's something i think that
ronnie jackson and others
have have raised that president biden i
think needs to prove
that he is up to this job because some
of these reactions just do not show
a commander-in-chief an american
president in control now remember
when president trump was in there the
press was combing
over every little utterance remember
they would say
president trump is unwell they had no
basis in fact for that whatsoever
they were combing through every annual
checkup that president trump had
they do this with every republican
president and yet we've got a democratic
president in there
when the press just throws up their
hands when it's clear to
everybody that there is some issue here
and yet no questions are raised it's a
thoroughly corrupt
press corps well and you know uh
joe when one of the the sound that we
played had to do with joe biden who
was very on top of his game whatever
came to hunter
he would say there's no conflict of
interest there's nothing wrong here
i'm not going to answer that i mean he
was well prepped on that
but you know it is amazing that he was
able to get away with that
and continues to be able to get away
with it when as we just said in the last
segment that you know hunter's getting
up to half a million dollars for his
artwork and the guy's not an artist
and you know is it going to be this way
for the next four years
i'm not sure about that judge only
because i look at the numbers i look at
the ratings i look at the clicks and
everything
is plunging at cnn for example cnn's
media show has lost 8 in 10 viewers a
ratings plunge of nearly 80
since the beginning of the year that is
consistent with the entire network
msnbc down nearly 50 percent since the
beginning of the year
you look at the new york times the
washington post subscriptions are down
when they rose obviously during the
trump administration so at some point
i would think that these folks would say
you know what maybe we
really should start doing our jobs and
hold the powerful accountable
despite party without fear or favor
to party if you want to stay in business
maybe you do that instead of being so
profoundly
predictable and in the numbers they tell
the story judge that that's the bottom
line
well it'll be interesting to watch over
the next few months especially as monica
indicated
uh the call by uh dr ronnie
jackson now uh congressman uh to have
the president submit to a cognitive test
joe koncha monica crowley thanks so much
for being with us hey sean hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else